how do you feel how do you fix the
educational system what do you do with
it do you do you so so I'm an 18 year
old kid you guys are counselors okay
because I mean this is where the
conversation starts yeah
I'm an 18 year old kid I'm a senior in
high school I'm an okay student 3.1 GPA
not gonna get a scholarship be be not
even a b-plus I'm just a B student I'm a
decent athlete I'm not gonna get a
scholarship
I'm a benchwarmer for my basketball team
decent shot not tall enough on 511 you
know I'm not no standout there's nothing
about me that's crazy have a decent
personality I've done some stuff here
what do you tell me to do what's your
advice your account if I may if I'm the
kid or the counselor no you're the
counsel okay so there's any model your
counselor not working for the school
parent or independent counsel so what do
you tell me so I think it's the fact
that an 18 year old or 17 year old kid
is making the biggest decision of their
life potentially other than who they're
marrying of taking on 50 $100,000 of
student debt not knowing what they want
to do with their life is a very very
tough decision to make
so I mean you can you know maybe it's
the Rockefellers who did this why do you
have to make this major major decision
in your life when you're 17 18 years
what do you telling me though so maybe
you take a year off and you just figure
out what you want to do in this world
like I there's no there's no rule that
says at 18 you need to go to school you
need to take on student daddy I need to
graduate in four years at 22 you need to
get your first year advice your advice
to me is don't go to Scott Whitney don't
play by the traditional rules I would
say if you know what you want to be like
Gary nester he wanted to be you in 15 I
want to be an FBI agent he knew that he
wanted to do that okay these days you
can Google what do I need to do to get
to be an FBI agent well you need a
four-year college degree you need to go
get training I don't know like for me
when I went to college I had no clue
what college I should go to I had no
clue what I wanted to do I was lucky
enough to get a football scholarship so
I got alright I guess I'm playing
football now but if I were 18 years old
again I would go get a job four years
there
to make some money you could always go
back to school when you're 19 the
question is I think we'd all agree
education is paramount right like if you
can get a free college education free
you take it dumb scholarship grants but
if you're talking about burying yourself
in student loan debt and just saying
well I just gotta want to figure it out
it's a very very slippery what would you
say what would you say your counselor
I'm an eighteen year old I'm graduating
what do you tell me so I would tell you
one of two things I would either say go
to a trade school because in reality
there's these kids that are coming up in
trade schools they're graduating and
some of them are making 70 80 90
thousand dollars a year in from a trade
school which I agree with if you know
that you want to be a plumber when
you're 18 years old or electrician a lot
of not a lot of kids want to do that so
but I agree with the trade school yeah
my other thing would be as sauce so
aptly says save that money okay so I
would say hey mom dad I'm not gonna go
to a $50,000 a year school all I'm gonna
ask is this if you'll continue letting
me live here but if you'll help me out
with my bills etc etc I'm not gonna ask
you to put that money in college and I
would say go find somebody that you
admire that you want to be like and go
intern for them for a year absolutely
free you get close to them you build
rapport uh you know you get their
contacts you do all this stuff like
Kaizen living testimony actually guys
the men yeah of him him coming here and
he's went all the way from Norway by the
way yeah from from Norway I'll come to
America the car doesn't sound anything
like that I just know you you you
literally just culturally appropriated
that accent there's gonna be people in
Norway being like Sol uvz bro you
totally sound like that guy that was a
man who's the youtuber that says I don't
understand why Susan she a party-pooper
she poop at the party
that sounds very German but no yeah okay
but the top is what you're saying go
shadow somebody's go
shadow summer school shadow somebody
Community College just the traditional
route has failed because you know what
American like here's what I'm thinking
I'm thinking about like is there is
there a time for a new form of Education
meaning for example is it time for you
know Google to have their own university
that you go to and it's only two twelve
months or 18 months or 24 months is it
well it's the time to go to Walmart
University or to go to I don't know at
all University and go there and while
I'm going through the class Apple can
use it as a form of filtering system to
hire me from 18 to 20 it's not even a
four-year program six-year program and
I'm kind of going it I just think I just
think I do think the cysts that the the
ability to have an organized system
because my dad when I was growing up he
was telling me something about parent
says when you parent kids kids need
order they need a certain system of
predictability they like surprises they
want to be surprised I want to have that
kind of stuff but they want something to
be predictable right so when the kids
were coming in here every day don't and
emic the kids were here every day every
single day they were here you saw too
many times reading [ __ ] it was a
system 102 shots a day one they read 40
pages a day to oldest minimum was 20
pages a day and then you go out and
watch a documentary today right that was
a system that we had this is not a you
know what he called at home school and
type of situation I'm a guy that's
running a business I'm running my zoom
here and he's sitting there reading a
book I'm doing a zoom here he's back to
shooting baskets I'm doing a zoom here
he's watching a documentary with over
there all I'm thinking about is I do
think an 18 year old his or her mind her
brain is not yet shaped they still need
some kind of a system and in order to go
through I just don't trust the current
educational system because the
curriculum are chosen by who by certain
form you know a protocol that they have
and you need these 17 classes to get
this kind of thing to get your
bachelor's right what if somebody just
changed it up and said listen here's
what you're gonna be doing come to our
school come to our company we have a
university format but this is what's
gonna happen you're gonna your teachers
not gonna be a college professor your
teacher is gonna be a CFO your teacher
is not gonna be college but for loving
me CMO it's gonna be the National Sales
Director it's going to be a product
developer it's going to be our
PR person is gonna be our HR person to
sign me out yeah that's what I'm saying
so what if you got that kind of a school
and I just don't think the current model
is an effective one
[Music]